what were your experiences on the apps I
felt like I was getting out of the apps
that I was looking for and what were you
looking for lots of sex are you on the
apps right now I'm kind of taking a
break right now you know there's a sort
of like extreme commodification and sort
of like view of myself as an object that
exists and we're more than that no
absolutely I mean like the whole profile
thing feels like an artist statement
meets like surgeon general's warning
meets like uh this product contains 120
calories you know oh absolutely and I'm
not light sized yeah would you define
sex as a date no yeah no I wouldn't even
describe most dates as dates what does a
date mean to you this attempt for two
people to come together to sort of like
sus out each other's mental illnesses to
figure out like how compatible their
broken is you know what I mean like that
feels like a date to me a date feels
like you're just going and you're lying
all the time to like get something and
I'm not very good at lying